[Scale Swap Challenge:]
[We asked three imaging specialists to swap scales and share their results.]
[#1: Photo to Micro]
[Keith Ellenbogen, Wildlife Photographer]
My name is Keith Ellenbogen,
I'm a wildlife photographer and I really
focus mostly on underwater environments.
I really enjoyed the challenge here of looking not
only just at big animals but now to look at these
microscopic, planktonic creatures. So I
went about and collected some plankton
and put them in a bowl. And here you can see a
concentrated amount of plankton that I sampled,
and then I took a little bit of this and
photographed it under a light microscope
using dark-field. And what I really enjoyed about
this is it's really the same skills I have. A lot
of patience, a lot of looking around, a lot of
finding the right animal and then photographing.
And this is what's called the novotny
which I looked up, it's cool, little.
I sort of like them because they have this
cone head kind of shape and you can see that
what is different a little bit from a microscope
in some ways, depth of field which in photography
is always omnipresent but it's much more present
in the microscope. And here one on the top is
sort of translucent and they just floated on the
surface they're really gorgeous, and you can see
inside it you can see it's pregnant with a
number of them, and they bloom really fast, and
I was learning about them, and you can see just
they're stacked one right on top of the other,
under a slide within a smallest drop of water. I
just I really love the the feeling of this this
image and and the discovery of this animal. This
is a dinoflagellate, it's a photosynthesis so it
takes the sun and makes a lot of the oxygen we
breathe. They're really spectacular they're very
present in the in the waters there they're the
most common one that I that I saw. And I liked it
because in this one, you know, it sort of moved a
little bit and I liked a little bit of the motion
that happened and I stacked the images, I took a
couple of these and brought them together so that
unlike the other one that the depth of field was
sort of merged together, and I liked playing with
this. I really found myself enjoying looking under
a microscope in a way that I've never really done.
And this is a larval crab that was kind of just
drifting, there you can see his two eyes. And
this was a little bigger, I think at the largest
size you can photograph under a microscope and
really too small for my for my lens but
I very much enjoyed this process and the
discovering an array of different animals
and I was surprised how much time,
it took a lot of time, just like my photography.
It's a whole amount of looking through each slide
was like a journey of a day of diving
it was really a wonderful experience.
And then I decided to try and collaborate with
a friend to go even smaller and this is using a
scanning electron microscope, and this is a diatom
so you can see this is extremely tiny here we're
at like one micrometer, and so it's just the
magnification is twenty thousand times it's,
you know we're right in there but this is very
different because it's not with the light and
you use your positioning and the focus is very
different I don't know really how to explain
it other than it's a lot of like controls and
looking on a screen and very different to how I
do it, and again the same search for how to find
wildlife and how to find the right diatom are
not all are the same some don't line up the right
way and it's all the same problems of photography
just at this minute scale. But I very
much enjoyed the process of learning.